This is for all the graduates.
Whether if you're graduating from high school, college,...
...talking with your mouth full, whatever, I don't know.
Let's put on flat hats and dream!
This sort of looks like a cat toy.
Dream about life!
Dream about what's next!
Let's dream about a world where people get along!
I mean, like, can't bass and treble be friends?
I'm looking at you, Meghan Trainor!
Life is like a really good sandwich.
It's all in how you make it!
So, fill it with the good stuff!
Fill your life with the good stuff, people!
We've been waiting for this moment and here we are.
It's a good moment.
All moments are if you take a moment.
As I look out here today, I see potential.
I see future surgeons and future teachers.
Future Beyonces!
I take that back; there's only one Beyonce.